[Music]
directioners brace yourself harry styles
is ready for a one direction reunion
well sort of he just told the spout
podcast it's not out of the question
i think the thought of it is this really
nice honor i'd love that be a time where
it felt like something we all wanted to
do i think we all went through something
really special together and there's a
lot of love there one direction was the
first uk group to debut at number one in
the us with their first album back in
2011.
[Music]
and continue to break records as one of
the best-selling boy bands of all time
you didn't even look at that when you're
in one direction it was a point where
you know people are saying oh you could
probably fart barbar black sheep on a
mic and it'll go to number one since
wendy went on hiatus liam payne harry
and their bandmates niall horan zayn
malik and louis tomlinson have all gone
on to have solo success
[Music]
liam was the last to go solo with his ep
in 2018
you know i love it when the music
baby and recently raised eyebrows when
he claimed he had the biggest debut
single of all the 1d solo careers
yeah we did the first song billion
streams
i think it outsold everybody within the
band and i was the last to go and i
never expected that
liam also came under fire for claiming
to be the band's lead singer part of the
reason one direction was made was
because of simon's promise to me that in
two years
i'll make this work for you wow so he
kind of started with my face and then
worked around
the rest of them never told us before
you you were you were the inception i
was the honorary member of one direction
yes now some fans are speculating that
zayn malik is clapping back by showing
off his impressive vocals to the group's
hit song you and if
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
naturally directioners would have all
the feels about the band getting back
together so we thank harry for giving us
hope yeah i think i think if there's a
moment for us to do it the right way it
could be great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you